and you talk about liberalism being the
dominant strain of thought in Parliament
and maybe in society in general what is
your issue with liberalism um to go back
to what I said before I think it I think
the basic problem is philosophically it
just privileges individual rights too
much and we were all for it when what we
are liberal but we're not liberals I
mean a lot of a lot of SDP positions are
quite nuanced so we're very prepared
being culturally very but we're not very
keen on the year
we're liberal but we're not two liberals
and I think that the prom with the
project the whole sort of emancipation
grand liberalisation project that we've
had since the 60s is that we've ended up
with a society and many fellow citizens
agree with this where me me me I come
first so the economic liberalism it's
all about getting as much money as I can
and getting ahead as far ahead as other
people as I can and the social
liberalism is about individual
emancipation what are my rights you know
how am I going to prosecute those rights
against the whole of the rest of the
society and demand I want this on that
now all of those things up to a point
it's I mean I think David good hearts
right about this I think in looking
about liberalism looking at liberalism
in terms of overreach have we got to a
stage where there is simply too much
mimimi and not enough us and I think
we're there honestly I think we're there
I think the the appeal of communitarian
parties now not not in the elites you
see the and there is a there's a very
big gap between what academics you know
but basically what what the Academy
business the media think is is basically
full-on liberalism and as possible as
much as possible you know with both
barrels and David again David good has a
great thinker on on this this this idea
of double-dose liberalism see societies
had you know 30 years of socialism
liberalism bang-bang-bang
it's the only one that speaks up as
other families you can't do that when
already counted with that it's an
individualism all the time and then eka
and then at the same time you
got the free-market liberals of the
right who hammer basically public
services have to be contracted out so
everything becomes marketized every
literally everywhere and at the same
time that the the state has lost
confidence to actually just directly
provide services and retain what should
be its its its domain I mean a key an
absolutely key
I'd say the cornerstone social and
economic idea and the SDP is the social
market economy which is something that
we introduced in British politics in the
80s and we're still there absolutely
that is the cornerstone idea and that's
the idea that the the state and the
market are not opponents do you think
we've reached this point now where you
sort of alluded to it where the pendulum
is swinging back against liberalism yeah
yeah and I think it is I think it is and
I think always that you can certainly
see that I mean if you take immigration
you know we're Pro immigration but we I
don't think we're pro mass immigration I
think and all and again but what does
that mean a lot of what people will mean
even make the distinction well magnitude
matters so an Academical Paul Moreland
came out of the book about migration
very recently and he made a point that
in the peak of the new labor immigration
expansion more people came to settle in
the UK than had ever arrived between
1066 and 1950 you know it could be a
million million people and that's that's
that's that's very high immigration now
again if you look at what the general
public think general public and even
leave voters by the way a eighty-five
percent of them are quite Pro
immigration they're happy with it as
long as it's it's basically of the right
scale now again to in the southeast
we're sitting here in Islington
to fail to have that much immigration
and fail to do the other side of the
tennis net which is to build enough
council houses and yes council houses
not to be sold off the state actually
doing something to help young people
meet you know pair up and start thinking
about raising a family
again the the economic liberals we don't
do that it's all left to the market well
actually they're just misaligned with
the public the public want the state to
help in in housing and you cut on any
millennial in the illness in the
southeast it's completely in favor of
the state do another matter how you
gonna get anywhere to live
[Music]